[Music]
criticize fauci all the time
well that could become a hate crime a
new scientific journal article suggests
adding criticism of scientists like dr
fauci
to the list of federal hate crimes
according to professor peter hotetz aka
idiot we must take steps to protect our
scientists
and take like oh please it takes swift
and positive action to counter the
growing wave of far-right
anti-science aggression
well that new law won't get abused at
all i actually don't mind fouchy but
now i'm calling him a stupid
be sure and bleep that because i don't
want to get in trouble
meanwhile a major backlash to obama's
birthday bash
and in its wake a lonely cake surging
cases of the delta variant have pooped
on barack obama's super sweet 60th party
in martha's vineyard
so instead of obama's party favors
including ventilators
he's changing plants according to the
new york post the obamas were planning
on having 700 people in attendance but
many thought
he was setting a bad example meaning
someone leaked it to the press
so they're shrinking the shindig so how
will celebrity guests handle
missing obama blow out the candle the
scaled back party means the planners
will have to
make some hard choices hmm we have got
to trim this guest list down
andrew cuomo oh boy pretend that invite
was never sent
chris cuomo you know wanted extra shrimp
for the protein crossed him
way off champ cuomo no way that guy's
hilarious
well that was quick laura
what do you make of hate crimes for
bashing scientists
are we still calling him a scientist now
yes
i mean really yeah if we're not allowed
to criticize somebody that has basically
given us whiplash from
changing his position on things over the
past year and a half i mean i don't even
know this
sounds like a communist idea if anything
this is crazy
it is crazy it is it's actually like an
author again
i hate doing the what if trump said this
oh my god but this is like this is an
authoritarian grab
also what if trump threw a 700 700
person birthday party for what if he had
a 200 person birthday party they would
have gone crazy over it but of course
it's okay because it's for obama
and the thing that bothers me about it
is he wouldn't have done anything
if not for people actually calling him
out on it he just wanted to kind of fly
under the radar about it
and just get it over with and then he
wasn't going to have you know any
consequences for it but
you know he got called out cat we were
for the party yes
we were fourth party because we we feel
that every like he
the party was a great signal to america
that we're getting you getting back to
normal it's like you know like if obama
can have 700 people
i can have seven people into my hot tub
yes
and that's usually half the capacity oh
yeah yeah well
unless we get you of capacity that's the
plus size models
um yeah and you know what i feel bad
because also you can you imagine how
stressful
that it must be to have 500 friends yes
that's incredibly stressful
uh and why do that if you can't have a
massive party with all of them
right i mean he's got i mean he how does
he have time to do anything else
but send happy birthday texts if you
have that many friends
truly and like just do it he was
vaccinated and tested like come on it's
never going to be any safer than that
you don't throw get wasted live your
best
barack obama life yes but you know what
you know what else
if he had thrown the party 500 famous
people
would would be busy for one day imagine
that they'd be like
all the famous people would disappear
they wouldn't be on twitter
but you know inviting 700 people
with the middle of this cobot thing
whatever it is
is so unwoke yes there's a part of me
that kind of says
you should have gone that's what i'm
saying
i mean he got he kind of got caught with
his mask off and his pants down yeah
but whatever that's happened to me 700
people in martha's vineyard
when all the woke people are screaming
and you know you can't challenge the
science because you're going to go to
jail
there's something kind of semi-cool
about that yeah he should have just made
it a 10 to 14 day rager
that way they're all quarantined there
you go there that's the best kind of
party yeah
that's the best kind of party and people
can show up and leave and
like some people get enough sleeping on
the floor it's like
like is he asleep or is he dead i don't
know poco oh yeah
great time great what do you think tyrus
first of all you're all extremely
inspirative and a bunch of jerks you
know i was invited
guess who's part of that 500. me
so thanks a lot guys i hope you're happy
should be a hate crime that i don't get
to go
i just wanted to go to be like why is
that guy oh man he's here he's too big
to say anything to you
so i could make my way all the way up
literally sit next to me what up dog and
he'd be like
how'd the fox news guy get here someone
want to tell him no you know what just
let him go just let me but now i can't i
can't have that joy
hate crying for dr fauci okay if we're
gonna do that let's be consistent
so the wicked witch of the view who
called the governor
a white supremacist a murderer
misogynist
eater of children shouldn't she be fired
yeah
she didn't have i mean that's pretty
much the worst thing you can say about
somebody on tv
yeah so shouldn't we be taking up arms
for that yeah
that's true or we all just pull up the
big boy pants and just call her a wicked
witch and move on with our day let's
grow up america but i am pissed i don't
get to go now
thanks greg well i'll let you know how
it is because we i was going to put you
in my backpack
and now it's ruined that's how we got
into lollapalooza
what's the new headcount he's 700 down
to what close family and friends and
apparently
that's 350. i was going to say but cat's
point that could be three or four
hundred people yeah he's got a lot of
close friends when you're the pr
president of the united states is still
somewhere hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else